I'm a stay at home work from home mum
and one of my favourite ways to start
the day is by setting a bit of a vibe in the house
we live in an almost 70 year old mid century home
and some rooms are naturally quite dark
so I like to pop some soft lighting on
maybe a record and choose a piece of art for the TV
cause she's an older home
she does seem to get a bit cold
so I’ll run the heat pump at least once a day
and clean up any crumbs that I find
left behind from the kids breakfast
at this point of the day
it's usually time for my second coffee
to fix myself some breakfast and sit down to my admin
I've been a customer of Powershop since we lived in our first house
six or seven years ago now
and part of my weekly admin routine is to play the Power Game
I think I have an app for pretty much everything
but this one is doing the most
because it allows me to take control of my power
and understand what we're using
month by month day by day or even hour by hour
there's five of us in this house and despite my best efforts
I would say we are a high use power family
so I find it extremely helpful to be able to browse the shop
and save money on Powerpacks
which are discounted packs of power
I can also pick up a Future Pack
so that's buying power at a discounted rate for months still yet to come
I really enjoy buying my power weekly because it keeps me mindful of our usage
and it means that I get stung with a big bill at the end of the month
and every time I open the app
it tells me how much I've saved
which motivates me to save even more
and if you're thinking about making the switch
Check my link below and you'll save $150 off your first 12 months
and it's basically girl math